The following video tutorial series
is going to be broken up into three main parts.
First, we're going to have an overview of some Blueprint
logic, Blueprint terminology, as well as
some C++ terminology.
Don't worry, you don't need to be an expert programmer.
We're just going to help define
what some of the terms mean and how
we use them so that everybody will be on the same page
moving forward.
We're then going to go over Unreal Motion graphics or UMG
just to give a quick overview of how it works,
what it is, what we use it for, and how
it can be used to help power any user interface interaction we'd
like to build in our project.
And then finally, we'll take all of the stuff
that we've done in this preamble
and apply that to our workshop, where
we will create a drivable car that can pick things up
and then has a timer and a score.
It's going to be really, really cool.
So let's go ahead and get started
with our Blueprint overview.